hier mon genre alors que se passe-t-il
et oui encore des déboires
malheureusement pour la campagne de
vaccination le vaccin astrazeneca est
administrée depuis samedi dernier aux
soignants de moins de 65 ans et depuis
les remontées négatives ont afflué ce
vaccin provoque chez certains un
syndrome grippal avec de fortes fièvres
de forts maux tête au point que 20 à 25%
du personnel vacciner de l'établissement
du chru de brest ont dû se mettre en
arrêt de travail
alors du fait de ce fait par dont
l'établissement brestois a décidé
d'interrompre la campagne même chose à
saint lô en vous le vous le mentionnez
et morlaix qui devait débuter la
campagne est bien là suspendu alors
l'agencé du médicament devant laquelle
je me trouve a informé hier à avoir reçu
149 déclaration de pharmacovigilance
entre le 6 février et le 10 février au
matin
cent quarante neuf sur dix mille
finalement donc l'institution relativise
elle attend des sujets plutôt jeunes en
moyenne 34 ans et ses symptômes et bien
ne dure pas et sont sans gravité
elle mentionne donc ces syndromes
grippaux de fortes intensités fièvre
élevée courbatures ou céphalées et
pour l'institution et bien ces effets
indésirables sont connus est prévu mais
en outre elle recommande aux
établissements d'échelonner les
injections afin que le personnel
soignant ne subissent pas les effets
secondaires de ce vaccin tous en même
temps
merci à catia pour toutes ces précisions